mari mccabe just want to talk
miss mccabe stop you think I want some
crazy magic totem things you are so not
gonna believe this
our very first external metahuman
sighting
check out that hotness
all I want to know is where it came from
who's your family
that would be the 52 million dollar
question
and me too totem or I will have one of
these men cute
I'm calling her thanks hey youtubers is
Charlie so this is gonna be my vixen
trailer from comic-con vixen is like the
next news show that the people that make
the air on the flash are making yes
they're also doing Supergirl but that's
gonna be a separate network vixen is
part of the CW's group of shows she's
just the next in a long line of Justice
League a listers that they're starting
to bring into the arrowverse gonna keep
my fingers crossed for new gods but
don't think we're gonna see them anytime
soon on TV so important stuff first I
seen a lot of you asking questions about
where this is gonna air how it's gonna
work and how it's gonna tie in with
arrow and the flash what the CW is doing
is it's premiering it on its seed
service that's like it's digital
distribution platform so all you need is
an internet connection you don't have to
have a cable subscription or anything
like that it's gonna start August 25th
that's actually the same week that fear
The Walking Dead starts so those two
shows will be like the next things that
I do weekly videos for because Doctor
Who doesn't start till September vixen
will be six episodes so it's almost kind
of like a mini series it will lead up to
the premiere of arrow in the flash so
the air the final episode like that the
Tuesday before the flash gets started so
you see is you see outwards it's the
same thing with fear The Walking Dead
it's like you know six episodes then BAM
main series starts yes vixen is going to
crossover with arrow in the flash in in
subtle ways it's mostly going to be a
one way crossover the intention is is
that it's going to create the context
for overt magic in the arrow universe so
whenever we get to actual arrow and
flash episodes they can talk about magic
and it'll exist and they'll have like a
point of reference they'll be like
remember that adventure we have with
vixen and it won't be just vapor where
they'll actually be episodes that you
can go back and reference now this first
season of vixen is gonna be an origin
story she's gonna learn all about her
heritage learned about the totem that
gives her her powers all the groundwork
that they did in the flash season one
and arrow season one what about live
action though is she going to be on the
live-action TV shows what they've said
nothing about that the actress that they
cast to do the voice for vixen
definitely looks like she belongs on the
CW show I mean she's got like the
certain level of hotness that they cast
for but they made no comment about that
but but I think the idea is is that if
vixen is successful she'll continue to
be a digital series and then they'll
bring her on for guest spots in the
live-action show eventually maybe in
future years
vixen is a character has mostly appeared
in other people's titles she did get
like a 2008 miniseries vixen return of
the lion but here's a really quick
rundown of her character's history in
the comics way back in ancient Africa a
warrior created a totem that allowed him
to harness the powers of the animal
kingdom he went on to become Africa's
first legendary hero now remember this
is the DC Universe so so Black Panther
does not exist in this universe moving
up to recent continuity Mary McCabe who
is the vixen character heard about the
legend of the tattoo totem from her
mother after poachers killed her mother
she went to live with the Reverend of
her village
Reverend G way he had the tattoo totem
with him but his brother killed him
trying to get it so so that's kind of
how she learned about the totem she lost
the totem to him not really
understanding how it worked
went to America and just tried to live a
normal life as Murray McCabe eventually
she returned to her home in Africa
learned about the totem and took it back
from her uncle becoming the superhero
vixen she joined the Justice League for
a little while they battled Amazo and a
bunch of other villains eventually
disbanded then she joined the Suicide
Squad for a little while she even had
some adventures with animal man like
like I said she normally showed up in
other people's titles she didn't rejoin
the Justice League till right around
identity crisis in the comics that was
right before Infinite Crisis there was a
storyline later in Justice League of
America vol 2 where her powers changed
and instead of drawing her powers from
animals around her she started leeching
on the powers of the people around her
so she could like leech Superman's
powers like anybody in the Justice
League that's a little more outlandish
so I'm not expecting that to happen on
the TV show I'm expecting them to stick
pretty close to the core of the
character where she just gets her powers
from animals what I'm really hoping is
is that the show invokes some of the
folklore around Anansi that's an African
God that was involved in the creation of
the totem itself in an ancient folklore
amongst many other things he's known as
the spider the trickster god so at
various times in the comics he's played
tricks on vixen like he actually at one
point he sucked her an animal man into
the totem itself when you look at comics
like Black Panther every once in a while
like they do invoke the Panther God like
the thing that actually powers the totem
that they use that gives them their
powers but I don't know how deep vixen
will get into that then they
might just reference it I don't know if
we'll actually see an on zeon the TV
show but if you're a big fan of African
mythology then you're really gonna like
vixen it's gonna be a lot of fun it
draws on African mythology in the way
that Wonder Woman draws on Greek
mythology even though the way her powers
work have changed in the comics I mean
you know that each story line plays with
that just a little bit it seems like on
the show she'll be able to use the
powers of multiple animals at the same
time like she's running at SuperSpeed
here and she punches very super far
usually the way they explain it is that
her level of power is just a function of
her ability to harness multiple
abilities at the same time so I mean the
more she learns about it the easier will
be for her to switch from power to power
to power if you want to read a really
good vixen storyline just read that 2008
miniseries
it's called vixen return of the lion she
goes back to Africa searching for her
mother's killers and has a sort of
Renaissance with her powers just based
on the trailer they showed I'm getting
really excited for the series I read her
during Justice League that there is like
a tie-in comic with the flash and arrow
if you haven't been reading it it's
called flash season zero in arrow season
2.5 I don't know how the arrow comic is
gonna change now that we're in arrow
season 3 but I think the flash season
zero is gonna stay season zero but they
they kind of tell the in-between stories
and things that they don't have time to
do on the TV shows like in this past
week's flash season zero comic they told
this really big Caitlin snow storyline
that they probably wouldn't have time
for on the TV show so if you want to
read more side stories with a lot of
these arrow flash characters just pick
up those comics but let me know what did
you guys think about vixen so far do you
know just based on this trailer and have
you read her in the comics before like
did you read her during Justice League I
think it'll be a lot of fun I mean it's
only six episodes so it's a relatively
low time commitment I'll be doing videos
for all of them so it'll be a lot of fun
it'll be a nice warm-up for flash and
arrow what's gonna happen next with the
show is I'm gonna do a couple more bonus
videos between now in the August
premiere remember that's August 25th
that's gonna be on a Tuesday but it'll
be a digital premiere so it's not on TV
I'll do a couple more bonus videos so
everyone's up to speed and then in one
of her episodes post I'll just I'll post
my episode videos within a couple hours
of it airing that'll also be around the
same time as fear The Walking Dead I
know I haven't started doing videos for
fear of the walking dead yet I've done
like a couple of trailer videos but look
out for those too like if you if you've
been watching the main show on Walking
Dead then you
I already know the tone of that will be
really close to the main show so there
are still a couple comic-con trailers
and a couple giveaways that I'm getting
ready to close down I'll try and post
those videos as fast as possible I'm
gonna be doing my ant-man spoilery
Easter Egg video NYX so be sure to
subscribe to get that if there is
anything that I haven't done yet
from Comic Con that you guys want me to
do just let me know in the comments so
while you guys wait for that you can
click here for my non-spoilery ant-man
review make sure you go see that it's
actually it's a really awesome movie and
you can click here for all my other
Comic Con trailers thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight